[Music]
on this wednesday night kids and covid19
vaccines
now that the u.s has approved vaccines
for five to 11 year olds what can
canadian parents expect and how can they
prepare sit down with your pediatrician
or your family physician and ask
questions
indigenous stewardship front and center
at the climate summit
and the growing pushback against carbon
offsets
plus it trouble a cyber attack cripples
newfoundland and labrador's health
network impacting thousands of patients
and raising the flag the sensitive
debate over when the time is right
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
some good news for millions of parents
waiting to get their kids vaccinated
against covid19 now that the american
centers for disease control has approved
the pfizer vaccine for children aged 5
to 11 years it's likely just a matter of
time before a health canada follows suit
the first doses are being administered
in american children this week so what's
the timeline for canada that's what
jamie morocco is looking into in our top
story tonight
montreal mom stephanie ventura has been
patiently waiting for health canada to
approve pfizer's pediatric coven 19
vaccine i just want to make sure that
it's given out and rolled out properly
so that
the kids that are high priority get it
including her seven-year-old son daniel
who has epilepsy and is living with
autism if he were to catch covid it
would be more detrimental to his health
than to actually get the covet vaccine
and to protect them you are the bravest
in the u.s kids under 12 are already
getting their first shots but here
there's some confusion on when canadians
can expect the same ottawa won't even
say when the shots are set to be
delivered
the issue really here is that in the u.s
the process for
approval is extremely open and
transparent whereas in canada the
process is very tight-lipped we don't
have a lot of this transparency
which ends up causing a lot of chaos and
confusion because people are just not
sure they just want answers some regions
have been preparing for november
rollouts but to add to the uncertainty
tuesday health canada tweeted the review
process alone could take months it later
deleted that message and replaced it
with one saying weeks the longer you
wait the you know a couple weeks that
you wait
there are more kids that are going to
get copic during that time in schools
ages 5 to 11 make up the largest
unvaccinated cohort still gathering one
in five new cova cases in canada are now
kids under 12. they're bearing the brunt
of a lot of these infections and even
though most of these infections will
turn out
to be fairly benign there are
implications
university of ottawa professor amir
aderan a dual u.s canadian citizen plans
to take his kids south of the border to
get their shot what canadians are
looking at here
is if they're lucky a one dose christmas
for their children more likely a zero
dose christmas
while american children will have two
doses and be fully protected
more confusion on an issue most parents
just want clarity on jamie morocco
global news toronto
ontario and quebec say they will not
require health care workers to be
vaccinated against covid19 in quebec
after pushing back the deadline several
times the health minister now says there
will be no vaccine mandate for health
care workers because it would cause
major staffing problems eight thousand
frontline health care workers remain
unvaccinated in quebec they will have to
take covid19 tests three times a week
and any new hires will have to be fully
vaccinated
in ontario it's been decided the
province-wide mandate is not needed in
part because most healthcare workers are
already vaccinated and the health
minister says she wants to avoid having
to cancel surgeries the way bc did after
its vaccine mandate
in british columbia for example they've
had
to cancel some of their scheduled
surgeries the concern that we had that
we would lose some of our precious
health human resources compared to a
relatively small number of outbreaks and
that's why the determination was made
ontario is also expanding the rollout of
covid19 booster shots starting saturday
roughly 2.75 million more ontarians will
be eligible for a booster dose that
includes people aged 70 and older
healthcare workers indigenous adults as
well as anyone who got two doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine they will receive
either pfizer or moderna it must be at
least six months since your second dose
the province plans to expand eligibility
to more age groups early next year
manitoba is now recommending all
indigenous adults in that province as
well as everyone aged 70 and up get a
booster shot
now we do worry that there could be
waning as we're in the fourth wave
we do have an ample supply of vaccine
and we want to protect older adults
air canada says more than 800 employees
have been suspended for not being fully
vaccinated the airline says most of its
27 thousand staff members did comply
with the federal vaccine mandate those
who did not are now on unpaid leave
now to the u.n climate conference in
glasgow and a big promise to shift
trillions of dollars in private capital
towards financing projects focused on
decarbonization former bank of canada
governor mark carney now the u.n climate
envoy has convinced an alliance of more
than 450 of the world's biggest banks
pension funds and asset managers to help
finance the transition of the global
economy to clean energy together they
represent over 160 trillion dollars in
assets kearney calls it a watershed
moment in the fight against climate
change
as the money is here but that money
needs net zero aligned projects
and there's a way to turn this into a
very very powerful virtuous circle and
that's that's the challenge
it's a shift but it doesn't mean
investment in fossil fuels is ending
crystal gomezing is at the cop 26
meeting in glasgow crystal
donna it is going to take an
astronomical amount of money to deal
with global warming getting private
money through world financial systems
quickly and effectively isn't going to
be easy but people here say there's no
alternative
whether from ecuador chile or canada
indigenous people here at cop26 say they
are united in the ways their communities
are being devastated by climate change
and they want the world to know all
these indigenous people who have come
here for the same reason
their lands are going
their people are sick they have no food
groups like indigenous climate action
based in edmonton say if governments and
businesses partnered with them they
could help achieve the goals of cop26
carbon markets and offsetting they say
do not serve as real solutions in
reality they're not actually reducing
emissions they're just kind of putting a
blanket over what's actually happening
canada is championing the idea of
putting a global price on carbon it is a
big part of our national strategy and
one more countries could adopt by the
end of the summit
carbon pricing
is one of the most effective
and cheapest ways to get there but not
everyone supports it it's a false
solution anything carbon-based is false
because it commodifies nature and the
land
wanting to hammer that message home
indigenous groups planned a rally
outside of a carbon market discussion
wednesday
however greta toomberg ended up being a
part of that session and given all of
the security they decided it was too
risky and called it off
she too has been a vocal opponent of
carbon pricing saying it doesn't address
root causes or force polluters to change
their behaviors valerie coutwa is the
director of the canadian indigenous
leadership initiative she says right now
the world needs more collaboration this
movement of indigenous-led conservation
and stewardship is absolutely
a response to the threat
that is coming um and and looming on us
that is climate change and biodiversity
loss people here say if world leaders
really want to tackle climate change
they'll focus on keeping the carbon in
the ground
donna all right crystal comancing in
glasgow thanks coal is the single
biggest emitter of greenhouse gases
followed closely by oil and gas and
though canada has cut back its reliance
on coal we do still ship millions of
tons of thermal coal overseas prime
minister trudeau has committed to ending
those exports by the end of this decade
the question is why can't it happen
faster here's eric sorenson
in 2019 canada exported 37 million tons
of coal including several tons of
thermal coal for electricity we've
committed to end
thermal coal exports by 2030. ottawa's
pledge to end those exports is not
happening quickly enough say
environmental organizations that
descended on the prime minister's office
this week they're demanding that exports
of thermal coal among the dirtiest of
fossil fuels should end within two years
it's hypocritical to continue to export
coal to be burned in other countries
where it has enormous health
implications and actually slows the
transition in those countries especially
developing countries away from coal
fired power canada exports coal
primarily from west coast ports much of
it for making steel but the country also
sends thermal coal to several asian
nations to power electricity and on top
of that canada exports thermal coal from
montana and wyoming coastal communities
on the u.s pacific coast have deemed
thermal coal too environmentally harmful
so tons of u.s coal is diverted through
the port of vancouver then on to asia
it's important that any coal ban also
ban the trans shipment of coal through
bc and other ports the federal
government says it will stop exports of
thermal coal from and through canada by
2030. environmentalists say by shipping
american thermal coal for years to come
canada will continue to contribute to
higher levels of greenhouse gases the
carbon emissions
that are produced from that level of
exports is the equivalent of eight
million cars every year and those are
emissions they're fueling the climate
crisis canada is moving quickly to end
burning coal for power at home
ontario shut down its coal-fired
electrical plants in dramatic fashion
years ago and alberta the biggest coal
producer is on pace to end burning coal
for power by 2023 ottawa has also
reinstated a federal review of a
proposed expansion of the vista coal
mine in alberta
critics say as a leader in phasing out
thermal coal use at home ottawa should
show bolder leadership and end thermal
coal exports by 2023
not 2030. eric sorensen global news
toronto
the government of newfoundland and
labrador confirms the huge disruption to
the province's health care system was
triggered by a cyber attack those
involved in the attack may actually be
monitoring what we are saying in media
and on the floor of the house
it's very important
therefore we don't do
or say anything
that compromises the efforts underway to
investigate and resolve this matter
it is unclear if any data has been lost
the province's provincial emergency
operations center has been activated
thousands of medical appointments and
non-emergency procedures have had to be
canceled
a bad night for president biden how u.s
state elections delivered a blow to the
democrats
[Music]
it was a night full of political
surprises in the u.s state elections
delivered a devastating blow to
democrats voters in key states like new
jersey and virginia turned away from the
party potentially signaling trouble for
the agenda of president joe biden
jackson proskow explains who won who
lost and what it means
all righty virginia we won this thing
republican victory shattered democrats
decade-long winning streak in virginia
the gop took the governor's mansion and
the legislature in a state that voted
heavily in favor of joe biden just one
year ago
in new jersey what should have been a
cakewalk turned into a dog fight the
democratic governor barely won
reelection there's no easy answer for
what went wrong for the party in power
local issues like education dominated in
virginia democrats tried to make the
campaign a referendum on donald trump
but it may have been the economy and
fears about inflation that won the night
for republicans everywhere this is one
of the issues that really flew below the
radar in the in these elections and is
really having an a significant impact
because people are not trusting the
biden administration and democratic
incumbents to handle it
if democrats misjudged the mood of the
nation republicans seized upon it
both parties are trying to find a
winning strategy for the 2022 midterms
when control of congress is up for grabs
the deep political division in the u.s
has actually caused both parties to
suffer from the exact same problem their
biggest names are deeply unpopular
president joe biden's approval rating
sits at just 42.9 percent 50 percent
have an unfavorable view of him and if
former president donald trump decides to
mount a comeback he'll find his numbers
are almost identical 53 percent of
americans have an unfavorable view of
him
we never
quit
that leaves state and local races as the
barometer of where americans stand today
right now the voting blocks with the
power to win elections are swaying away
from the party that swept to power last
november
jackson prosko global news washington
in australia a four-year-old girl is
back home with her parents after she
vanished from the family's campsite 18
days ago this is the moment police found
her
they say they found the girl after
breaking into a locked house at night
and when she was asked who she was she
said my name is cleo
they say officers involved in the search
wept with relief a mass of land and sea
search was mounted in the sparsely
populated region on the assumption the
girl had wandered from the tent but
evidence began to support an abduction
and led police to the house a
36-year-old man is in custody
still ahead the sensitive conversation
around when to raise the canadian flag
when flags were lowered across the
country in may many canadians were just
beginning to take in what indigenous
leaders had known for years children who
died at residential schools were buried
in unmarked graves lost and forgotten by
the system there is still much work to
be done and many questions to be
resolved including when is the right
time to raise the flag again
abigail beeman reports
tim olone is indigenous he's a veteran
and he says his family was devastated by
residential schools he has unique
insights into the complicated question
of when to raise the flag i don't have
an answer but my gut is telling me it
should not be now because you know for
all we know there could be a school
found with 500 children
tomorrow while flags at federal
buildings are still at half-mast on
remembrance day the war memorial flag
will be at the top of the flagpole then
lowered to honor those who served some
legions have already hoisted their flags
as for after the ceremony if they wish
to then leave them lowered in
remembrance of our first nations friends
after that period that is up to them
chief cadmus delorme of the kausas first
nation where 751 unmarked graves were
found supports raising and lowering the
flag for veterans as long as it's then
raised and lowered again in remembrance
of unmarked graves when we find
the need to you know
figure out you know the end goal to
raise that flag that conversation will
come when this country
truly implements the truth and
reconciliation calls to action the prime
minister hasn't offered a clear path
forward i'm confident that the
conversations with indigenous leadership
on making sure we are able
to
lower the flags once again on
november 11th
will
come at the right solution conservative
leader aaron o'toole believes it's time
to raise them we have to put the flag
back up so it can be brought down
to support both remembrance and
reconciliation i think it's important
for the country to do both o'toole says
he's spoken to many including indigenous
veterans who support raising it but the
native women's association of canada
says it's more divisive even if the flag
was raised only for remembrance day it's
not clear
that you know you can raise the flag on
that day then lower it without really
hurting someone on one side or the other
difficult choices with remembrance day a
week away
abigail beeman global news ottawa
next what parents need to know about
kids and covid19 vaccines
we've been talking about covid19
vaccines for a long time now there's a
flood of information available about
their safety and efficacy we're not
going to go over all of that again but
now that children aged 5 to 11 are being
vaccinated in the u.s and approval is
expected soon here in canada it is worth
talking about children and vaccines with
me is dr isaac boga she's an
epidemiologist and specialist in
infectious disease dr bogash the
evidence is overwhelming that covet 19
vaccines are safe and effective in
adults and prevent serious illness and
death in the u.s now they're going to be
used on kids age 5 to 11. that only
happens though after rigorous
examination of the safety and efficacy
what do we know about that process there
was a clinical trial that enrolled about
4 000 children
looking at the the pfizer vaccine which
we're talking about here for kids this
is a smaller dose of a vaccine uh in
that study it looked like these kids
mounted a very reasonable immune
response similar to what adults would
mount with the adult dose of the vaccine
and there were no safety signals in this
study of course
this is a smaller study you're not going
to see these rare rare rare side effects
like the inflammation of the heart also
known as myocarditis and of course that
will be looked at as this vaccine is
ruled out it's expected to be a rare but
of course not zero percent risk and of
course based on all the scientists that
looked over this at the at the cdc and
all the specials that looked into this
they felt that the vaccine was a very
reasonable and safe approach to take and
provide significant benefit to the five
to 11 year old crowd and just quickly
what is a safety signal and then how
rigorous is the approval process here in
canada
yeah safety signals would be things like
adverse events related to the vaccine i
think it's fair to say that of course
it's not going to be zero we know that
there is inflammation of the heart
associated with the vaccine we also know
that the virus itself can cause
inflammation of the heart in actually a
much greater frequency than the vaccine
uh and of course health canada will be
looking at all the data from the
clinical studies all the manufacturing
data and they'll look at all that and i
think it's fair to say that in the
coming weeks we'll probably see this
approved here in canada i should i
should point out too that you know i
think it's it's pretty clear that these
vaccines are not only very safe but also
very effective in reducing the risk of
coping 19 especially reducing severe
outcomes from the virus
and we're told kids are going to get a
smaller dose why is that
important
yeah i mean it's fair to say that you
know kids are not small adults the
immunology is slightly different
the adult dose for example of the pfizer
vaccine for the 12 and up crowd was 30
micrograms of mrna and it's a third of
that in in children that's really
important and of course in the in the
clinical studies that were done
the uh that smaller dose in the five to
11 year old crowd looked like it was
provided a comparable immune response
there's been so much misinformation
disinformation about cobin 19 vaccines
in adults i think we can safely expect
the same will happen
with the vaccines for kids what is the
best way for parents to avoid going down
those rabbit holes
yeah i obviously have to be very careful
where you get information from i think
there's a few very high quality
incredible sources you can look to your
your municipal your provincial and your
federal public health web pages they
have excellent information and it's
updated in real time i think the best
thing though is we know that many
parents will have questions about these
vaccines and it's hard to predict every
possible question that will come up
the best thing to do is to sit down with
your pediatrician or your family
physician whoever's looking after you
and your children now and ask questions
because you know we have a bit of a gift
of time this is probably still weeks
away in canada and now is a wonderful
time to sit down ask your questions
and and really have personalized
treatment here so that when vaccines do
roll around we we know that your
questions are addressed
that's great advice thank you dr isaac
bogash in toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is ottawa there are
beautiful spots all over this country
please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]